[Music]
gus
roberts you are my number one installer
and who better to train up more gus
roberts's than gus roberts himself the
last thing i need is some clueless
millennial mouth breather cluttering up
my van
elton i really should have asked you to
wait outside
hello we're here to fix your broadband
have you ever had a paranormal
experience this is my youtube channel
the most haunted institute
of the criminally insane savior
[Music]
i don't want anything to do with ghosts
ever again oh i think i'm being chased
by ghosts
[Music]
i saw a smoldering ghost
can you help me
something is not right we need to find
out what it is
you're just scratching the surface
there's a bigger world out there
you're in danger these aren't just
restless spirits
these are malevolent entities welcome
truth seekers what an old ham how long
is this boring bastard gonna be
waffling off dad everyone here you know
we're on the cusp of something
russians the chinese they're watching me
says and the cast of the incantation
should take not more than one sip of
tepid
yeah urine before the ritual begins
[Music]
[Music]
you